- INTERMISSION!
- [hums]
both: OH, OTHELLO
IS MY SHITE!
- [bleep]-ETH, YEAH.
- OTHELLO, MOTHER[bleep]!
[both imitating
swordplay sounds]
- [bleep],
YOU DEAD, WHITE PERSON.
[laughter]
OH, THIS PLAY DOTH SEEM DOPE
TO ME, MARTINSIA.
- VERILY, LASHAWNIA.
VERILY.
YO, AND 'TIS ABOUT TIME
SHAKESPEARE DOTH SCRIVEN
THE PLAY THAT PLACES A BROTHER
AMONGST THE FIRMAMENTS.
- THAT'S MY SHITE!
- OH, WHO'S YOUR FAVORITE
CHARACTER?
MINE'S OTHELLO.
- OH, 'TIS MINE AS WELL.
'TIS MINE AS WELL.
- BECAUSE THEY GOT OTHELLO
AS A GENERAL.
I'M SAYING, HELLETH, YES.
- AND OTHELLO DID THE BEAST
WITH TWO BACKS
WITH THAT COMELY WHITE MAIDEN,
AND DIDST NOT ANYONE
SPEAKETH AGAINST HIM.
- MM.
- HE STRAIGHT PIMPIN'.
- METHINKS THINGS ARE LOOKING UP
FOR PEOPLE OF THE DARKER HUE.
- DAMN STRAIGHT.
- HOO.
both: ♪ HEY, NONNY, NONNY,
TALKING HEY, NONNY, NONNY ♪
- COME ON.
- OH, HEY, MARTINSIA.
- MM.
- WOULDST THAT I COULD BORROW
A COUPLE OF DUCATS
TO PURCHASETH A CAPON
FROM YONDER CONCESSION?
- PSSH, MOOR, PLEASE.
YOU KNOW I GOT
A CONCEALED CORNISH GAME HEN
UP IN MY DOUBLET.
- OOH, ALLOWETH ME TO PARTAKETH
UP IN THIS BITCH.
- OKAY, OKAY.
GET IN THERE.
[bell dings]
- THE SECOND ACT
IS ABOUT TO BEGIN.
- COME ON, Y'ALL.
Y'ALL HEARD THE URSHER.
- IF I KNOW SHAKESPEARE,
OTHELLO'S ABOUT TO KILL
EVERYBODY UP IN THIS BITCH.
[laughs]
NO, NO, NO,
MM-MM, I HATETH THIS PLAY.
- HOW THEY GONNA KILL OTHELLO?
- MAN, THAT TRIFLING ASS IAGO,
I KNEW HE WAS UP TO SOMETHING.
THEY SHOULD HAVE KILLED HIM
IN THE FIRST ACT.
- HOW THEY GONNA KILL OTHELLO?
- HOW OTHELLO GONNA DO HIMSELF
IN WITH A DAGGER
HOW DOTH THAT HAPPEN?
- LET ME TELL YOU SOMETHING,
IF A BROTHER KILL HIMSELF
EVERY TIME HE BROKE UP
WITH A WHITE BITCH, THIS WORLD
WOULD BE BEREFT OF BROTHERS.
- YOU'D BE TALKING
TO A SKULL RIGHT NOW.
- OKAY?
- WHERE'S SHAKESPEARES AT?
- SHAKESPEARES.
- OH, HE'S RIGHT THERE.
both: PRITHEE.
PRITHEE.
- MAKE WAY.
PRITHEE. MAKE WAY.
BE GONE, CIRA.
YOU KILLED OTHELLO!
- A BLACK MAN GOT IT GOING ON,
AND YOU SHUFFLE OFF
HIS MORTAL COIL?
- I SAY UNTO THEE
THAT'S A TRAGEDY.
- MM-HMM.
- OH, 'TIS THAT NOT
THE TROUBADOUR KANYE
OF THE WEST?
- WHAT? WHERE'S--
WAIT.
- TRUTH BE TOLD, MY LORDS,
'TIS NOT I WHO PENNED
THIS DREADFUL PLAY.
'TWAS CHRISTOPHER MARLOWE.
both: NAY, NAY, NAY.
- YES, IT WAS.
- THOU ALREADY TRIED TO USE
THAT LINE OF ARGUMENT
WHEN THE JEWS WANTED
TO KICK YOUR ASS
AFTER THE MERCHANT OF VENICE.
- WE DOTH NOT PURCHASE IT,
SLICK WILLY.
WE DOTH NOT PURCHASE IT.
- BE CALM, MY GOOD LORDS.
'TWILL NOT BE LONG
BEFORE ANOTHER BLACK HERO
GRACETH THE STAGE, AND NOW
IF YOU'LL LET ME TAKE MY LEAVE.
- NOT SO FAST.
YOU GOING TO WRITE
THAT HERO NOW.
- VERILY THAT, MOTHER[bleep].
[both exclaiming
and imitating funk music]
THAT JOHN SHAFTE
IS ONE BAD MOTHER--
- SHUT THAT MOUTH.
- I JUST SPEAKETH ABOUT SHAFTE.
- MM.
- YO, LEVI, MAN.